This guy is pushing 40 and he's blamed all of this on everybody
else because I don't have YouTube money. Um the Kickstart doesn't
pay out as well as it used to. >> By the way, none of this
gets into the hidden audio recordings, of which there are multiple.
And he has to he has to lie to himself and his audience now about
what actually happened, right? He just has to he has to lie about
it. You are guilty of everything. Everything she accuses you
of you are guilty of.
This is some from Desty stream today. 60 comments. There are
60 comments on this. Jesus Christ, man. What?
Holy. Okay.
Uh, Omni Liberal is having a hard time financially right now.
>> You really make considerable money for each regular
stream if it's worth skipping events for grinding streams. It's
not worth it to skip.
Wait, no. Yes. I The only money they make right now is from streaming
on kick. So, when I do events, it cost me a considerable amount
of money. Yes. And then I'm getting squeezed from way too many
places right now with zero external support. cuz I don't have
YouTube money. Um the Kickstart doesn't count as well as it used
to. >> Zero external support. What's the external support?
Is he talking about like don't what from Z with zero external?
It's just like inherently framing it as you're the victim automatically
again
just the huge victim
external support. Like I I feel like he's asking for donations,
right? He's just asking for donations. Zero external support
cuz I don't have YouTube money. Um the kick stuff doesn't pay
out as well as it used to and then between court costs
and then taking time off to travel and do events or whatever.
It's a lot. It's a big a big old squeeze.
I'd still be shocked. Do you really make I I would you know
personally if I were Destiny I would just like stop doing
like just stop stop breaking the law. Stop breaking to right.
If you want to get these platforms back, if you want to make
money, I would just suggest those things
probably the best option. The kick statement confirms botting
to me or the DG chat is really his payouts. I I wonder if he
got forced to actually multiream because I know he used to not
turn the toggle on for multi streaming. I wonder if he's actually
getting forced to multiream now. Be interesting to know how destiny
it's everybody else. Yeah, I stop breaking the law like the liar
LIAR CLIP. STOP BREAKING THE LAW.
You know, that's pretty pretty simple.
I think
probably should have settled the case. Well, I think there's
a clip somewhere floating out there where he explains that he
hasn't why he hasn't settled the
Should we Who's got that clip? Somebody link me that clip. We'll
do that clip as well cuz that clip was particularly That clip
me off particularly. Okay, that clip was actually super annoying.
It It's like lying in multiple dimensions.
Very goofy. Okay,
dude. that substance clip right there.
Was there another one? Oh, he um he talks about the the progressive
victory event. Let's check this out. Did you see Vos and Mike
working with the soy pill and Mr. Beat at a PV event? Yeah, I
thought progressive victory was dark money. Kind of crazy that
I guess they changed their mind on that. That event looks like
it's going to be god awful. Holy [__] Somebody horrible
to people there. Jesus. Why they invited Vos, Dylan, and Soy
Pill, but not you. Isn't it be also controversial? Well, cuz
I'm like a super center left liver dude. What do you mean? Also,
I'm pretty sure I've openly fought with the new all the new >> Oh,
we covered this last night. I was like, dude, no.
Listen, they're lefties, okay? The penalty, all right, the the
penalty for being a liberal in that coalition is nothing. No,
never mind. >> Maybe people are like tankies. So,
>> you you can only
minor if you're a communist. Okay? If you're a lefty, if you're
a liberal, you don't get to do that. All right? So that's a that's
a privilege we're going to reserve for Vosch. And if you want
to embrace socialism, Destiny, you can have the same privilege.
Okay.
>> That's it. That's how it is. All right. We got that
one. I mean, he's complaining about all this stuff cuz at some
other point he complains about dark >> Did you see Vos
and Mike working? I guess they changed their mind on that >> Yeah,
maybe he did. >> Yeah, I thought Professor Victor was dark
money. Kind of crazy. >> Yeah. Nobody So people's problem
isn't the dark money. Sorry, I People's problem isn't the dark
money necessarily.
It is the lack of disclosure,
right?
Like people were okay with PV and you remember this because a
lot of people were talking about the PB stuff. People were okay
with it so long as was as it was disclosed.
Like people do understand that Republicans are using these same
funding mechanisms. And if liberals or leftists want to fight
back against that, they might have to take money in the same
way.
Right? If there's a loophole there and you're just going to not
take advantage of it, that's
But then the lack of disclosure on the creator side is that's
what creates the problem. People don't want to consume content
when they're unaware that it's being paid for. That's it,
right? All of these people are disclosing that they're associating
with PV. All these people, I'm guessing if they were paid, they
would disclose this, right?
I noticed the the PV tweet was kind of funny as well. Hold on.
jealousy thy name is. What's his name again?
It's kind of funny. A little funny. I appreciate it. Okay, I
appreciate it. All right. And then we've got two other clips
that we're going to do here.
Allowing Solo to get away. This is the one I was talking about.
Okay. This is the one I was talking about. This is kind of goofy.
I think I think I'm going to be very annoyed with with both of
these clips, but we'll see. allowing Solo to get away at the
Omni Liberal refuses to give info on Solo to the FBI. I don't
know how long I have to sue that guy. I need cooperation from
some from people, but JTO server harassed them victim so much
that I don't know what the appetite would be for them to help.
Wow. For for the victim to help. So, he needs the victim to help
him. We'll we'll we can go into a little bit of this. Okay. Is
that solar guy going to walk away from this unset? That's probably
the thing that upsets me the most is that um >> Does it
upset you? You protected this guy from the beginning. Destiny
was the one who could have gone and tried to find this guy's
information if he'd involved the cops or if he'd involved like
some civil if he'd gone for some sort of civil case, but he just
didn't. He didn't pursue anything. >> I I I I don't know
if Yeah, I just I don't know at this point. I don't know. I'd
have to check what the statute of limitations is on anything.
And then um because I don't even know how long I have to sue
that guy. So that's pretty annoying. And then I >> So when
he first talked about this, he literally said he could have done
something. He could have gone to the cops. he could have sued
this person,
but he felt really sad because Pixie sued him, so he didn't want
to do it. That was what he said before. The story has changed
again to well actually I just I haven't done it and I don't know
if I'll ever be able to. And you hear the sigh. >> It's
also a matter of like I need a little bit of cooperation from
individuals for that to work as well. But now that um Pixie Joone
and Justicle's Discord have harassed, you know, like one of the
victims so much, >> apparently it's Pixie and Jones discord
now, too. Pixie Jo and Justicles Discord. Okay, maybe As far
as I know, the only person who ever had contact with Rose was
one person. Why? Why would this involve my Discord? It didn't
involve my Discord at the time. It didn't involve my Discord
ever. It's Joan Joan is Pixie's lawyer, right? One, it also wasn't
harassment, but I'm not even going to get into litigating that,
okay? It was also those two people talking and one person helping
the other. Okay? So, I I wouldn't even see that it's harassment,
but I don't care to have that conversation right now, even if
it were it was one person who was contacting her. And there is
nothing wrong. The the way you determine that this is harassment,
by the way, is by saying that Destiny is the victim and Pixie
is attacking him because otherwise it was just Pixie through
a proxy reaching out to this person to be deposed for her court
case. You have to have the framing in your head that Destiny
is the eternal victim
or it's just literally one person helping another person. Now,
if Destiny thinks it's inappropriate for people to reach out
to that victim, I would wonder why he reached out as the person
that this this girl was apparently traffic to. He is the purchaser
of the traffic materials. Okay, he's the customer for the traffic
materials.
He reached out personally knowing that she knows his face, knowing
that she knows who he is. He reached out on Facebook to her directly.
Would that not be harassment? So why why would you do that? Why
would you do that? Purchase her. He paid for it. Uh how did he
get her her what do you call it? Her uh cash app. And even if
by the way, okay, hold on. Hold on. You're right. You're right.
You're right. I don't know for sure that he purchased it. I thought
he did cuz he had the cash app and everything. But let's say
he didn't. Let's say he got it for free. So, he got the traffic
materials for free. He knows that the girl knows who he is, right?
We all know that. And he reached out to her directly on Facebook.
Isn't that kind of weird? Now, let's let's go back a little bit
in time. How was this girl found? How was this victim found?
Was it
what what happened there? Who who put out the information? Who
put out the pictures that allowed her to be found?
Oh, that was Destiny 2.
That was also Destiny.
That was Destiny going, "Oh, well, here are a whole bunch of
pictures, Kiwi Farms," in his own in his own chat, right? "Oh,
there's here's a whole bunch of pictures, Kiwi farmers. Go and
try to find this person."
Which he then told somebody else on Twitter, literally publicly,
he told somebody else, "Well, I did that. Of course, I tried
to dox her because I had to find her." So, he doesn't even deny
this. He admits it personally, right? and he accuses my discord
of dox of of not even doxing of harassment
because of one person. It's a totally fabric. It's totally sad.
It's totally fabricated. But you have you have people who are
stupid enough to believe it. Very sad.
Very sad individuals are gay. Oh my goodness.
>> You know, like one of the victims so much I don't know
what this person's appetite would even be um for anything like
that too. Like that might that whole path might be maybe completely
ruined. So I'm not sure. cuz that's all the guy's going to walk.
Amazing. Amazing. He's the eternal victim.
The total complete and utter victim here, guys. Harassed one
of the victims so much. It's like, dude, she helped and then
she was deposed.
I I just Did she say something about this in her deposition?
In the deposition, did she say that she felt like harassed?
Was that the concern or was she concerned about Destiny helping
her get doxed?
Which one was she concerned about? I forget. We have another
clip here. What is this? No accountability taken. At the omni
liberal gives his recounting on his controversy over distributing
material of women he's had interactions with on film. Suggests
he was catfished and that Pixie was manipulated by a scorned
lover of his into suing him. Does he mention that he was sending
this he was sending out this that he shot with other people without
their consent to multiple women and that multiple people have
accused him and that like m there's multiple instances from this
one thing.
Does he mention any of that? Molina accused him of doing it.
Astagia accused him of doing it there. Uh Abby accused him of
doing it. And there's at least one other victim of just that
alone. Yeah.
Of just that.
I'm sure he starts there, right? Well, I was I was distributing
a bunch of people's without their consent and then Right. It
definitely starts there like at the actual impetus. No, >> vague.
I mean, I've already said it all. I was just putting all the
pieces together. There is like a crazy mega right-wing woman
who scorned a lover, gets the opportunity through Pixie, who
was a girl who decided to have her hoe face but was embarrassed
and didn't want to come out, who um through leaks that happened
from a UK.
He actually he he blames this on everybody else. This guy is
pushing 40 and he's blamed all of this on everybody
He is the original violator of consent here. By the way, none
of this gets into the hidden audio recordings, of which there
are multiple,
right? None of it gets into that at all. That um catfish me over
two Oh, hold on. That um catfish me over two to three years um
with a girl that he had seduced on an app for minors. Uh that
was legal on Kiwi. By the way,
while I will say that the deposition says that she never talked
to Destiny,
the solo person said she talked to Destiny directly. And if she
participated in that account at all, that account is proof of
her distributing child, right? if she participated, if she used
that account. I'm telling you, it's very obvious from the audio
that Destiny is recording with his phone in his pocket and that
the other person is unaware of this farms and then weaponized
by like by a community that hates me and then propagated through
a discord with a guy who ended up secretly dating um the very
same BPD chick that he said was unethical for me to hook up with
and it came out that you've been dating for. >> Didn't
say it was unethical for you to hook up with her at all. I I
never said that.
You just made that up. This is a to another totally made up thing.
He just has to totally make up all of this. Never once claimed
that you can't date somebody who is mentally ill ever in my entire
life. I would never do that. That's an insane thing to say.
Just show me the clip. Show me the clip of ever of me ever saying
anything like that ever. Ever.
Okay. >> Months and was threatening her and then paying
her money to keep her. There's just the whole thing is just like
so unbelievably crazy. It's just all of it is just so stupid.
All of it together. It's just Yeah, it's just unreal. It's just
a total fabrication.
It's an total and obvious fabrication. Very sad. And like multiple
fabrications built on top of each other. Why does his mouth movement
look like AI? I have no idea. I don't even know what you're referring
to, Reven Rubin. I actually don't know. No clue, man.
There's one more that I wanted to cover. He refused to settle
the case. Why he refuses to settle the case? That he's like getting
blackmailed or something. We're going to do that one as well.
her. So, she extorted me for a million dollars, but the legal
demand was 15 million. So, when she was Why Wait, weren't there
a bunch more messages about that that demand? Wasn't she like
very embarrassed about that demand? Like, she basically was like
just expressing how upset she was. Does anybody around this not
I would love to know notes opinion. I would love to know Straight's
opinion. I would love to know almost anybody's opinion on this.
Like not that I would expect any of them to answer, but just
like did anybody really think that Pixie was asking for a million
dollars in DMs.
Did anybody really think that?
Okay, but it's going to get even better. Okay, it's going to
get even better. >> Suicide baiting. That was when she
was making the $1 million request, which I'm never I'm just never
giving it to I'm never I don't give any blackmail. You can't
blackmail. You just say release your like what am I going to
do? I'm not Yeah, I'm not going to do I'm not going to doated
blackmail. And then the legal demands were 15 million and she's
never budged from that. And als
uh that's a total lie. And Destiny knows she's budged from that,
right? That's like an obvious lie.
We had another call and then her lawyer was like, "Uh, something
along the lines like, "Okay, wait, wait, wait. What about like
just make me like make me an offer over 150k?" I'm like, "This
is Oh, it's even lower than I thought. Make me an offer over
150k." So, how could it be that Pixie's lawyer, by the way, this
is from February 19th, 2025,
how could it be that they've never budged from $15
but they said make me an offer above 150K? How could this be
the case? How could this be the case?
Come on, man.
That's total extortion.
What the man? This guy just can't stop coping. He can't stop
coping.
He spent five, six, seven times and he has to he has to lie to
himself and his audience now about what actually happened, right?
He just has to he has to lie about it because otherwise he's
a complete
if he spent over a million dollars litigating this case and they
didn't want anything close to that, then he is a total
for continuing it. He looks totally embarrassing,
right?
So he has to lie about it now. I don't give any blackmail. You
can't if somebody's going to blackmail you say release your like
what am I going to do? I'm not Yeah, I'm not going to do I'm
not going to doated blackmail. And then the legal demands were
15 million and she's never budged from that. And also like oh
even the complaint doesn't ask for 50 million. It's for 2 million.
Yeah, exactly.
Sorry. Also that is a pre like the 15 million thing was like
hey we're suing you. This is how much we want. As in like to
not continue with these negotiations to not continue talking
at all. That's how much. And then pretty much immediately they
go, "Well, make an offer above 150." Obviously, right? Obviously,
there keep in mind there's a different cost. You're buying different
things with each of those. So, remember, any settlement we do
is going to come out with me always looking basically like a
It's like people are going to assume the worst because any settlement
we do, even if we have like non-disparagement clauses, even if
we release like a mutual statement, it's just going to be impossible
because people are going to like, "Oh, he probably bought her
off because he was guilty of everything." Right? So, you are
guilty of everything. Everything she accuses you of you are guilty
of. You did share people's audio without their consent. Uh with
recorded it without their consent, say shared it without their
consent. You did share videos of her without her consent. You
did share videos of Molina without her consent. You did share
videos of Abby without her consent. You did share videos of Stashia
without her consent. This is all bolted on. Everybody knows this.
It's very obvious, man.
It's very, very obvious. Why are you just lying? Just repeatedly
lying, right? I a lot of people I think oh my god apparently
Wick talked to some guy and Wick said like oh well I need a court
case to figure this out. Why why would you need a court case?
What is a court case going to tell you that Destiny couldn't
do himself? Right? If he had consent with these people to share
their videos, why wouldn't he just post those conversations?
Um he has a known track record for doing this thing, right? He's
done it with Molina before. Did it with Molina again. Like there's
an obvious known track record of doing this thing. Why? What
more is required for a moral indictment? I understand that legally
there could be more required or something, right? For Pixie,
I don't know if she's ever found uh aside from the Abby stuff,
any evidence that Destiny sent this to other people. >> Well,
Wick Wick just wants to make money obviously, which is fine.
I mean, it's if that's what you want to do. I Hey, sometimes
people do morally gray or morally black things for money. It
happens. sent it after. Yeah, sorry. So, Destiny did send the
video of Pixie without her consent, but it was before the current
the the Cardi statute came into play, right? And so, the the
legal case basically is stalled on trying to figure out well,
is there an is there an instance of her him sending it after?
There is. I think they seem to be going to trial. I have no idea
what's actually going on with that case, though, to be honest
with you. >> Anyway, so it you know, it is what it is.
Do we do we get things with each of those? So remember any settlement
we do is going to come out with me always looking basically like
a it's like people are going to assume the worst because any
settlement we do even if we have like non-disparagement clauses
even if we release like a mutual statement. It's just going to
be impossible because people are just going to like oh he probably
bought her off because by the way you know what would have worked
you know what could have totally worked and wouldn't have had
a whole bunch of his friends bail on him.
>> I I would have been out no matter what. But a whole
bunch of people could have easily been kept around him
>> if he had just gone, "Oh, I reallyed up here and I'm
gonna have to I'm going to have to take some time off and work
on some and I'll be back and I'll be
>> Super easy.
>> But he didn't do that. He had to attack the reputation,
who these people are, right? And he spent a year and a half degrading
Pixie's reputation as much as possible online, such that when
it originally happened, everybody went, "Oh, Pixie's like really
nice and and Pixie like this. She's sort of like a perfect victim.
And now they're like Pixie is a gold digging disgusting.
Pixie is like this total. She was everybody.
Cool. Cool. Very cool.
>> It's just crazy. It's crazy.
>> Wild stuff, man.
>> No shot. Everyone I I know multiple people who have
spoken to me who would not have distanced would wouldn't have
like distanced privately.
if he had just taken some responsibility. If he had just said
like, "This is really [__] up of me to do. I apologize.
I'm going to be better. Get get some help." Clearly, he's got
impulse control issues that are leading to him violating consent
at this kind of scale, right?
>> Could have gone to seek some help. Didn't want to. You
know, it is what it
>> Oh god, it's streaming through it backfired because
he got demonetized. Well, I mean, that was on a totally unrelated
thing.
What was Dest's reaction when you distanced yourself? Uh, well,
>> I had unique circumstances there.
>> That I'm probably never ever litigating
>> Um, I basically
>> Yeah, I can't I I can't litigate it publicly. So, I've
agreed not to talk about stuff with person I was in my previous
relationship with, not talk about her stuff online. So, I I have
to be super careful about that because it was an agreement I
made. Okay.
>> I mean, yeah, beyond that, we it's >> like a close
friend or whatever. So,
>> putting Pixie in the cycle did him in. Jesus Christ,
man.
>> Uh, he did ban me.
>> I didn't need to like basically it worked out that I
didn't really need confirmation of stuff from him. I didn't need
to do like like some um Would you say confrontation with him?
>> So he was guilty of everything. >> He was not
a fan of me though. He was not a fan of me.
>> Okay. All right. All right. I think that's it for the
Destiny clips. I think that's basically all of it. We could go
I Oh, it's good that I did find this though. This one was important
to >> more aggressive. >> I do really think it's
like actually very important to point this out, right? that when
he says it's the $15 million thing, when he continues to to bill
all of these out of their money in time and says 50 million,
50 million, 50 million, my 15 million, it was 150,000. That was
what they asked for. That was where he said, "No, no, no. I'm
not going to do this." Right? So, one, he's economically
definitely his lawyers would have said, "Oh, no. We should talk.
We should talk about that 50k.
No, you should do that. That's going to be way better than than
potentially going to trial on this, right? But wasn't willing
to entertain it. Wasn't willing to do it. Okay, that's the number.
That was the number she asked for. 150K. That was what he did
all of this for. That's what he blew this all up for. That's
why, by the way, he blocked Pixie, right? When she was talking
to him, he blocked her.
Totally said, "I'm not talking to you anymore."
All of his friends said that was a huge mistake, by the way.
Thank god he didn't take that deal. I don't know, man. I I feel
like that would have been better for a lot of people if he'd
just taken the the deal.
150k, a threemale response charge from Brettler. Well, not quite,
but Brett does charge a lot. And he was also the middleman. Speaking
of not so aerodite. Okay, there's a funny clip with her that
we're going to have to cover. There's two funny clips. Okay,
two very, very, very funny clips. Where's the Aerodite clip?
He tweeted this. Right there it is. I I think the Aerodite clip
actually misses something. Hold on. I think there's an archive
of this clip that I could look at.
Mark Carney,
>> bro, can this guy just stop with the bad
It's crazy.
Mark Carney, I spit on you. What the Mark Carney ising amazing.
This is like classic Natsuite, right? She like actually isn't
going to look at the clip first to see what he's mad about. She
just immediately goes, "Actually, I love Hassan, right? I love
Hassan or sorry, I love Mark Carney. God damn it." She doesn't
even wait to see the clip. She goes, "I love Mark Carney. How
could he ever do anything bad?" It's like, that's not how you
should look at it. Why don't you look at what Mark Carney did
or said and then decide,
Why would you inherently just because of who Mark Carney is defend
him
before anything happens? I do like Mark Carney, but I again you'd
have to see what he actually said to know >> what
why why are you so mad at Mark
>> Hold on. >> Cool. Cool voice >> and important.
>> You son of a [__] You came out in Davos.
who said middle powers need to rise up and and and
dignify themselves and develop sovereignty for themselves. We
will no longer be bullied. Why? Because Donald Trump said he
was going to treat
white European. I think Hassan would have really disliked that
speech to begin with because it involves the like derealization
that was taking place in the USSR.
And so I'm sure Hassan didn't like that speech in the first place,
right? Like that is the basis as he's describing the situation
in the USSR and how they dealt with circumstances that were kind
of felt beyond their control and how they couldn't handle it.
Right. Oh, he liked it. Okay. I'm just saying I I think the basis
for that speech would be annoying to him in the first place.
>> In countries like he treats nations in the periphery.
For once,
you saw middle powers
speak out. Or at least Mark Carney spoke out. >> What is
he mad about here?
Wait, he did he did speak out.
she he rolled back and was like, I need the context
and then goes, what is he mad about here? You're listening for
that. That's what you're listening for.
You clearly didn't go back far enough cuz you probably would
have seen the quote if you went back further, right? So now you
can wait for it to come up again or
whatever. But he's he clearly >> Sovereign nations are
speaking up because of poor treatment of their sovereign nation.
But he's not speak I'm assuming my steel man of this is he's
mad that Mark Carney didn't he said white so I'm assuming he's
mad that nobody has spoken up previously about the way that Trump
has treated like brown countries
the kind of not Trump though America through the history of America
like America in collaboration with a lot of these powers in Hassan's
worldview has basically profited and and denigrated the global
south for like a long period of time,
And now that Trump is treating Canada and some other white countries
like the global south, they go, "Oh, we actually need to like
band together." That's Hassan's view on this. I think that seems
to be what his view is, right? I would assume that's his view
is he thinks Mark Carney was joining like, "Hey, it's actually
wrong to treat us like pieces of it's actually wrong for you
to do this." And he thought, "Oh, that meant well, they're standing
up for the little guys." issue is
I think a lot of them actually have
but also when you're talking about a new world order of trade
negotiations you don't have to be talking like yes you're allowed
to talk about your own nation and should talk about your own
nation
>> Mark Carney speaking today >> yeah know she's
the probably unaware of what he's going >> as well
>> he spoke out today he said Israel has a right to defend
itself
>> okay
well that's true >> doesn't Israel the right to exist?
Didn't Nazi Germany have the right to exist? What's wrong, guys?
Can Germany not defend itself?
Is Germany supposed to not defend itself? In 1938,
1939, 1938, is Germany not supposed to defend itself, guys? Does
Nazi Germany not have the right to defend itself? Now, I can
admit the Holocaust is worse than what Israel is doing, but it's
the same vibe. It's the same kind of thing. Hey, they are territorially
bullying people. They're they're building up their own military
to bully people who aren't ready for it and they're planning
land grabs, it seems, right? That's that's the problem.
Well, I mean, also the ethnic cleansing aparttheid, but that's
what we're looking at here. That is the problem.
>> So, do I think this is overall a bad thing? Do I >> Okay,
so yeah, just Israel. It's just Israel posting.
Oh, no.
Oh, it it's always comes down. >> Oh god. Wait, what?
>> So, do I think this is overall a bad thing? Do I >> Okay,
yeah, just Israel.
>> Wait, did I not go back? Israel >> has a right
to defend itself. >> Israel's right to defend itself. >> Well,
that's true. >> So, do I think this is overall a bad thing?
Do I >> Okay, yeah, just Israel. It's just Israel posting.
Oh, no.
Oh, it always comes down to the I saw a clipped. >> This
is classic.
So, she's doing the conflation, right? I thought it wasn't supposed
to be the conflation. Why is she doing the conflation of anti-ionism
and anti-semitism?
Immediately
just goes to, "Well, that's anti-semitic."
Well, you don't think Israel has the right to defend itself?
You You have some questions there. Well, that's anti-semitic
immediately.
Well, that's anti-semitic before I hear anything else.
Dude, it's actually it's pretty crazy, right?
And she does the conflation. the conflation that she'll get mad
at everybody else for doing. Why?
>> Today I can't I I probably won't be able to find it
now. There was a clip today where Gad Sad was on Joe Rogan and
he says, "How many do you think there are in the world?
It's Oh, I need I wish I could find the clip. It's so Hold on.
Let me see if I can find it for you guys. It's so funny.
Is she There's no way that she was is going to do the whole how
many are in the world.
So is it somebody is going to be a maybe Joe Rogan? Maybe somebody
else. Somebody's going to be a complete and that's supposed to
mean something. That's supposed to mean like anything. I'm going
to find an example of somebody being stupid and accidentally
anti-semitic or anti-ionist in a way that look makes them look
silly. I'm just going to show you propaganda. Hey, why don't
you do the same bit, but show all of those apartment buildings
being blown up in Lebanon? Show Gaza being totally leveled and
then go, nice one. You think this is bad, anti-semite, Israel
has the right to defend itself. Go look at the thing we're actually
upset about. Don't look at some and try to paint everybody else's
that. Don't do
Don't do this, you know, smoking mirrors, this misdirect to some.
It's It's a wild thing to do. It's so funny because his answer
is so stupid, but he walks you through his thought process
and it's even worse. It's somehow
worse. Like, >> his answer's >> insanely dumb. But
then when you think about how much thought process he put into
it, >> who is Gad Sad? He is like a right-wing. He's sort
of like he's sort of like the Weinstein. I feel like he's from
>> the same group of people. He's kind of like one of the
Weinstein type people who was a part of that like dark enlightenment
sphere
and became like a massive Trump supporter despite sort of having
liberal leanings before that,
>> right? It's this guy. If you've ever seen him on Twitter,
he you you probably recognize like the PFP
is this guy, right?
>> Yeah. That's who Gad is.
and he still came to the conclusion that he did. Okay, let's
see if I could find
Wow.
Her that was so unpalatable. Her microphone gave up on trying
to communicate it to us. Thank God. Thank you. W that sure SM7B.
That is the real hero today. That actually saved all of us from
having to hear that in full force. Okay, let's see if I can find
it.
Oh yes, here it is. Hold on. Okay, hold on. Hold on. Oh, it's
so good. It's so
>> That's me making a new joke. >> Who watches this?
Who Who watches this?
I want a genuine Aerodite viewer to come on here and explain
precisely
precisely to me what they get out of this. What are you getting
out of this? What are you getting out of this? What do you get?
>> I will answer this question in like a second. Okay.
>> For example, Judaism. You mentioned earlier Judaism.
Do you know how many kids there are in the world?
Not to put you on the spot. >> 12. What? >> No, I
don't know. >> Just take Yes. >> You want to take
just not not to put you on the spot. >> Okay. Let me think.
>> How many How many >> There's seven billion people
in the >> Okay. The
I forget what percentage of the population died in the Holocaust.
Was it more than 50% more than half of the Jews? And that was
6 million. So, it's at least 12 million. And then I remember
seeing a news post that they just only recently recovered. Oh,
but his population in Europe had only recently recovered. So,
I'm guessing it's on the order of like 10 to 30. Somewhere between
10 and 30, >> I would guess. >> First of all, >> 10
and 25, maybe 10. Maybe 10 and 30 with Israel. Somewhere in there.
There hasn't been Oh,
there hasn't been 7 billion people in the world in like years.
I think we're at nine now. Okay. But I need He's already starting
going. So, let's just let's say he genu Okay, he thinks it's
7 billion. It's not the end of the world. It's two billion off.
It's just two billion whatever. But okay, he thinks there's 7
billion people on the planet.
>> There would be >> this is this is the only way
you can defend Israel. We're going to talk about how stupid Joe
Rogan is. Joe Joe Rogan's really really really dumb. Guys, support
>> Look Look, Joe Rogan's going to think there's so many
in the world. Doesn't Israel have the right to defend itself?
He's somewhere in the neighborhood of a
>> He's legitimately like squeaking,
Again, I just feel like this is the wrong attitude to take. What
is What is
Yeah, Joe Rogan is dumb. Joe Rogan is uniquely dumb, but she's
like squeaking laughing at this guy being dumb.
I think we all move past Joe. Yeah, Joe. Joe Rogan's a total
like years ago. Obviously, he thinks
17th of the world is Isa real in your opinion.
No, but
>> I I don't care that it's an old clip. It's a funny clip.
It's hilarious.
It's crazy. Like to guess like say he says just take a guess
and he goes, I don't know, like a billion. That'd be like a crazy
number, but like he's just like picking a random number. He literally
went, "Well, there's 7 billion people in the world, so 1 billion,
bro.
>> I honestly,
I'm not joking. I feel like if you go look at that,
I'm going to I'm going to take the edgiest position on planet
Earth." I bet you Joe Rogan is like actually joking there. I
bet you that's not a sincere like answer
cuz I'm just thinking like even boomers know like, "Oh, China's
got about a billion people." You don't think there's as many
Chinese people as there are people, right?
I I honestly I'm sitting there. I'm like, he might actually be
joking.
>> But hey, he's also I'm not shocked that he's a Okay,
>> I'm just saying I could see it. I could have seen it.
>> But I you'd have to go look. And who really cares?
>> There's only like what 7 to 9 million people that live
in Israel. So even if you like reasonably assume
that the diaspora is like double that would put you anywhere
from like
12 to like 18 million in the world. Bro literally thinks 12 to
18th
of the world population.
I think he just threw out a number in Jess. He didn't just throw
out a number. He said well there's 7 billion. So 1 billion. He
he at least tried to quantify and process his way through this.
Okay, that's why we are with the Joe we are nowadays. Okay, this
is the processing that we've got going on. >> A billion.
Uh Jamie, you want to take >> maybe 500 million? Maybe
I'm going to I'm going to take a very conservative guess. I'm
going to change it to 500
>> Yeah, this guy's just got no idea what populations are.
>> 500 million is a conservative guess.
>> We did this. You're going to be shocked. >> Okay,
we got all to think >> 13 to 15 million Jews. >> That's
not in New York. >> You're out of your [__]
mind. >> No, just look it up. >> Shut shut the mic
off. This guy's >> Unfortunately,
when a group gets genocided as regularly and often as Jews do.
There's not a lot of them. Okay. They keep on getting their [__]
kicked in, unfortunately. So, you're right. He was serious. He
was serious.
>> Amazing. Best clip I've seen in >> um the Holocaust,
like I said, knocked the European population down really
I don't I knew how many there were. Um
but do you want to know do you want to know the real reason there
are like not that many people? Honestly, it's like pretty easy
to understand what the reason is. Um one is they're usually minorities
in countries and for a long time, yes, that was something that
got you like pramed eventually, right? But another huge thing
is the religious aspect that like you literally have to be insular
in that community that if your mother's not you're not considered
for a very long time, right? That has a huge that is a huge factor
in how many people join this like ethno religion. It's very insular
by its nature.
>> He's an agent. >> Let let I'm a Zionist chill.
Uh let let Jamie now do his little Google magic. >> Okay.
And then he goes on about Muslims and whatever. There's more
Muslims. surprise.
Okay.
Why am I showing you this? Oh, yeah. People,
Dude, why am I Wait, why am I EVEN DOING THIS? OH, RIGHT. Han
is bad,
dude. That's awesome. That was awesome. I knew there was a reason
I didn't go to the clip. I knew there was a reason to watch this
whole thing. Let's go >> like this. Make me think that
he would also guess that there's a billion in the
Oh, come on. You think Hassan No, no, no, not at all. I'm going
to show you a total saying something totally because I don't
want to contend with what Hzan's actually saying. So, I'm going
to show you Joe Rogan and I'm going to pretend that they're the
same person.
Very cool. the like everything comes back to the and it's like
guys they are a tiny portion of the world population and I get
uh and wait and
what dude what other tiny portion of the world population is
currently devastating totally obliterating the livelihood the
standard of living of multiple countries right now. Who else
is doing that? Why is it happening? Why is it allowed?
This is just a dodge. I don't care how many people are Well,
I mean, we're talking about the actions of Israel, so talking
about the world population is already putting this content
in a very weird context, right?
Like at the very beginning, I
I could have sworn that most liberals say you shouldn't conflate
Zionism and and anti sorry, anti-ionism and anti-semitism
because that leads to people being targeted. But okay, that's
that's fine. I know Israel is not most of the world's population.
I know that. But is the actions of Israel even smaller subset,
right? But the actions of Israel are leading to very very negative
consequences. The policy of Israel is leading to very very negative
consequences for the entire planet. Does she not believe this?
What does she not believe? I I don't know what she This is such
a weird dodge. It's just like it's honest to God propaganda,
right?
What do you even mean? Um, actually there aren't that many Jews
in the world. Therefore, why do you think this is a problem with
with Israel? Well, I mean, even before October 7th, Hassad would
say there's a genocide going on there. So, being like uh saying
Israel is the right to exist. Well, you shouldn't have the right
to exist so long as you are oppressing a people that brutally.
That's like like you shouldn't defend that oppression with does
Israel have the right to exist. That's insane. That's an insane
statement. >> Get it. BB Netany sucks. I'm not a big fan
of what's going on in Gaza. There are Oh my god,
it's concentrated. I'm going to go back and I'm gonna have to
pause it multiple times here. So, I'm going to go back. We're
going to watch >> You would also guess that there's a billion
in the world.
Like everything comes back to the
anti-semitism. >> Tiny portion of the world population.
And I get it. BB Netany sucks. I'm not a big fan of what's going
on in Gaza. There are
>> I'm not a big fan of what's going on in Gaza. What is
going on in Gaza? Has Kyla talked about what's going on in Gaza?
What is going on in Gaza, Kyla? Could you lay that out for me?
What is going on? Because again, this is actually, it's funny,
I could just replay exactly what I said for the Gavin Newsome
segment, right? You say, "Well, I'm not a fan of BB Netanyahu
or what's going on in Gaza." Okay, Kyla, do you think what happened
in Gaza would have been different if I if any of the top three
candidates for leadership in Israel going to this election were
elected?
Answer is no. They are in lock step. Okay, they're in lock step.
So trying to blame it on BB Netany and Yahoo is totally nonsensical.
It makes no sense
It's the country. The country wants that to happen.
There will be protests about it. There will be people who are
against it. I salute those people. I appreciate those people.
I love those people. Okay? But they are not the majority of that
country. And they will not cause that country's politics to significantly
shift in the very short f like in the near future. Okay? The
politics of that country are not shifting anytime soon. And so
people need to step in. People need to step up and say something.
And what that's going to require is the one thing that Kyla and
Destiny and a whole bunch of people on that side will never do.
It's going to require swallowing your pride and admitting that
you were wrong about Israel not going insane,
right? You were wrong saying, "Well, actually, it's not really
a genocide and actually like up until now it's kind of been fine
and actually like maybe Israel isn't that bad." You were wrong.
You will have to admit you are wrong to rejoin the side with
the rest of humanity. You will have to admit you are wrong. that
un unconditional unequivocal support for this country is wrong.
But I don't think they're there yet. I don't think they're ready
for that yet. Right,
dude. Gavin Newsome did the same thing. EXACT SAME RESPONSE.
I DON'T SUPPORT BBnet Yahoo and I don't like what's going on
in Gaza. What's going on in Gaza, dude? Naftali Bennett number
two, sorry. Yeah, number two on Poly Market for odds for the
next election to become the leader, right?
He was on Piers Morgan 2, three days ago talking about how they
had actually made all of Gaza a terrorist city and everything
had to be destroyed because they made it entirely a terrorist
city.
Literally everything there. He justified everything they did.
He would not have made a single different decision. It's it's
crazy. And you don't care to look deeper into the politics at
all. You don't give a Okay,
so talk about what what is actually happening in Gaza. What do
you think is happening in Gaza? What do you think is happening
in Lebanon? And why do you think BB being out would change what's
happening?
>> Are many issues that we can have with >> Oh, Natali
Bennett is pro-settlement and expansion. Well, that's good. That's
good that he's next. He's the next man up, the next most effective.
He did go on Joe Rogan and he talked about how in Judea and Samaria,
many are dying, killed by Palestinians.
He did say this. Yeah, Piers didn't quite get it. Piers doesn't
know what he's saying there. I guess Piers didn't want to call
him out on it. They just moved on.
But yeah, he's pretty clear about it when he talks. >> The
issue is there are many issues that we can have unfortunately
with a lot of countries that nobody >> Okay. Wait, do you
think Wait, does she think
Okay,
there's actually a problem we could have with a lot of countries.
Okay, let's roll right off the top. How many other countries
does the US give their latest weaponry to? How many other countries
does the US give that much aid to? that much military aid. How
many other countries does the US give that level of security
guarantee to that are perpetrating these exact crimes that are
doing this exact thing? Answer one.
Answer one.
It's not a whole bunch of countries, right? US taxpayer dollars
are being used to perpetrate these crimes. US technology is being
used to perpetrate these crimes.
So, while they may be having like a genocide in Sudan, in Sudan,
I I understand that. I would be critical of it, but is the US
funding it? Are they directly providing the weapons? Are they
directly providing a security guarantee for anybody who disputes
who wants to go after Israel for doing it? Are they tipping the
entire country in that direction? Oh, the UAE is doing it. Cool.
UAE is doing something similar. Wouldn't be shocked. But hold
on, my one. You know what the UAE doesn't have? Same level of
military technology as Israel. Do you know why that is? Because
Israel is the only one allowed to have that by law. By US law,
Israel are the only people who are allowed to have the latest
American technology. Curious
>> he's interested in talking about because it doesn't
serve their like satisfying narrative of like America and its
allies bad and everything else good, right? It's just like
>> why would it be about that? What? What?
I'm totally on America's side in every other conflict.
I'm totally on America's side versus Taiwan. I'm totally on America's
side supporting Ukraine against Russia. These are the three major
like geopolitical conflict areas that everybody has an eye on
and everybody talks about with any regularity. I don't think
America bad in all those other cases.
She's just she's just making something up. She's just trying
to fight a straw man. I it it has nothing to do like you can't
just say, "Oh, well, you just think America bad when people are
dying. Their housing, their homes, their infrastructure, their
bridges, everything that allows them to continue their way of
life is being obliterated." You cannot say, "Well, you just think
America bad." It's a total thought terminating cliche. You are
a you are a totally unprincipled a immoral hack when you say
this. Okay? Just you know what I need Kyla to do? Honest to God,
don't talk about world. Don't talk about geopolitics. Leave that
off the table. Okay? Stop talking about Hassan. Just hold your
hands over your head like everybody's there for and collect maximum
donations. Okay? Hands up.
Don't shoot a load yet because I'm not I've not collected enough
money. Okay? So, just hands up. Hands up, Aridite. Okay? And
collect the money the exact way you know how to and stop talking
about geopolitics. Thank you.
It's just always got to come back to the And it's like it doesn't
actually always need to come back to the My thing is every time
>> This does come back to Israel. She does a weird conflation
again. It does come back to Israel.
Absolutely it does. If you've been following along with this
conflict, Israel has essentially established some way of influencing
the president beyond America's own intelligence agencies and
they are feeding him explicit lies to get him to go to war. Yes,
it comes back to Israel. I'm sorry. It does.
And again, you would have to if you looked into this information,
you would have to admit you're wrong. So, you do not want to.
What is it? all comes back to the total the global economy is
being totally destabilized
for war in the Middle East
at the insistence at the behest of Israel. Yes. And BB Netanyahu.
Yes. The president is trusting MSAD over his own intelligence
agencies. Yes.
It seems to be getting cleared up a little bit now. Thank God.
It seems like possibly he's starting to say, "Oh, actually, BB,
I I maybe can't trust you, you know. got into the war, realized
BB lied about everything,
and now he's going, "Hey, no, I'm not going to tell those people
to rise up. I saw everything. I saw the intelligence from your
own agencies. They think those people are going to GET KILLED.
WHY WOULD I TELL them to rise up? I'm not a monster, BB. It's
almost like you're evil. It's almost like you just want blood
to flow." Bi, do you covet death?
Wait, what? What are you doing here, BB? Do you just want You
just want maximum carnage? What?
That's so hopefully Trump started to wake up to that a little
bit. But
okay, let's uh let's continue. >> And it's like it doesn't
actually always need to come back to the My thing is every time
people like go back to the I'm like how many Persians are in
the exact same position? >> Oh my god.
How many Persians are in the exact same position?
We're talking about
Everybody's talking about the genocide
in Gaza.
Okay. Everybody's talking about the war in Iran where Israel
is targeting a bunch of like civilian infrastructure and biohazards
that are going to affect the health the long-term health of every
single person in Tyrron currently.
Right. This is what we're talking about. Those are the Persians
getting How dare you invoke the Persians when they are getting
when they're getting murdered in droves. Why would you invoke
the Persians? That's ex That's
incredibly egregious actually.
I I don't know how to soy about that correctly because normally
I don't. Why would you? What? >> How many Persian doctors
are there? How many Persian lawyers are there? Okay. Really?
It's time for the PQ. Okay. You think it's >> Oh, she's
just totally obiscating, moving away from the real questions.
This isn't about people being lawyers.
Why would you try to turn Why would you try to trivialize the
issue by turning this into Well, actually, a lot of Persian people
are lawyers.
What? Totally totally trivializing the issue. I don't know if
she's doing this without getting paid. If she's doing this without
a paycheck, she's like a totally despicable, degenerate human
being. I mean, obviously she still is as if it's for a paycheck,
but like at least I understand people selling their souls. Like,
I can understand when you are going to take money and you're
going to do something against your principles because it's going
to set you up to like maybe have a better life in the future.
I understand that trap people fall into. I can understand that.
I can I can understand the rationalization.
If you're not getting paid for this level of like rhetoric, this
this level of
I that's somehow worse to me. It's It's like totally despicable.
the Jews. They're Persians. They're getting their fingers in
everything. They're very highly educated. They like immigration.
Okay. They're in music. Hollywood. Lots of comedians. Persian.
Just saying. Just saying. What are they doing all over the place?
Okay. It's so It's like a total again. It's like the It's just
a total minstrel show. Like she's just doing She's just like
shucking and jing out here. SHE'S SHUCKING AND JING. I'M JUST
SAYING. She's doing all the dude. What is this? What is this
goofy ass pan? They're Persians. They're getting their fingers
in everything. They're very highly educated. They like immigration.
Okay. They're in music. Hollywood. Lots of comedians. Persian.
Just saying. Just saying. What are they doing all over the place?
Okay. It's so annoying. It's so annoying. And like, does she
think that's anybody's criticism of Israel? that lots of people
are in positions of like wealth that they're doctors and
I don't think anybody even goes gets in on the for that. What
are we doing? This is Hall of Fame rage bait. It's just particularly
egregious. Yeah,
it's particularly egregious. And this is on this is by the way
with the backdrop of the it coming out that there's not been
a prosecution for a killed Palestinian in the West Bank since
2020. It's on the back in the back like basically happening in
the background. Le Israel annexing southern Lebanon. Not annexing,
sorry. Um occupying southern Lebanon, blowing up bridges, blowing
up apartment buildings. Um nothing's gotten better in Gaza on
the backdrop of total humanitarian disaster in Iran. War started
by Israel and Iran devastating the global economy. It's on the
backdrop of that Palestinian child. Sorry, it was a Palestinian
child, right, that had the cigarette burns, tortured by the IDF,
21 months old and tortured by the IDF
to extract a confession from their
It's on the backdrop of all of that. Aerodite goes out and does
this stuff. She trivializes everybody's outrage, but you need
to know the actual events happening, right? The outrage is
And the goofy ass Mr. Rex the goofy ass like, "Oh, look over
here." Well, what's the definition of genocide?
Stop blowing stuff up. Stop blowing up. Stop destroying the quality
of life of all these people such that they leave on their own.
>> I get it. You think if you if you can tell people to
get out of the area cuz you're going to bomb everything and you
bomb a bunch of You think because the casualty count won't be
as high that we're all going to let that go. But we're done letting
it go. We're actually done letting it go. When you blow up these
people's ability to live their lives, when you totally destroy
their ability to have a happy, prosperous life for decades in
the area, you're the problem. You are the problem.
And I don't care. I I watched I watched Nefelli Bennett last
night. I watched this interview where he described, well, actually,
what Hezbollah does is they've got like retractable roofs on
their housing and in a bedroom they'll have like missile launchers.
Bro, these people are not
inspect gadget. They're not maggyver jerryrigging these retractable
roofs.
Shut the up. It's actually just crazy. And okay, given all that,
that's all just on the moral level. Beyond that, why should US
taxpayer dollars go towards that campaign? Why should the US
provide a security guarantee such that Israel can continue on
with these kinds of campaigns? Why,
bro? Like, at this point, I feel like the Saudis are far more
considerate of human life than Israel, which is crazy cuz the
Saudis are psychotic.
>> Okay, it's insane.
>> What? How did the US even get the balls to not veto
the condemnation from the UN of Saudi of the Saudi Arabians trying
to starve the Yemen? How did they even get the balls to do that,
dude? How do you How mad do you think NBS was? NBS sitting there
like, "If we were Israel, you wouldn't do this. If we if we were
Israel, you just let us starve them. What the America?
What the
>> dude? It's It's crazy." >> Like people like, "But
I really hate Apac. Apac. Apac." And every time I hear Apac,
I'm like, I feel >> nobody nobody listen, people do talk
about Apac a lot. Sure, people do talk about Apac. That's not
what this issue is. That's not what everybody's outraged about
over right now. People don't like Apac. They don't like that
it is essentially foreign money coming in under the guise of
like it's it's lobbying by a group of Americans on behalf of
a foreign country that is like totally only the only interest
is that foreign country and it is very successful and very strong
in terms of its lobby, right? is very influential.
And this might be a case of actually people just tend to follow
bureaucracy really well and they're very effective and that's
upsetting to me, right? They're so good at it that we need to
actually add restrictions to it. That it could just be that.
It could be, you know, skill diff
get good. But even if it is just get good. They are too good
at it. They are too effective. Okay, that is that is the case.
feel like we're just saying because I also don't like carry committees
but I hate Apac for the same reason I hate every single
carry committee which is a foreign in this carry committees are
not inherently foreign what I hate Apac for the same reason I
hate every carry committee it's
that's not
>> that's not carry committees
I believe wasn't progressive victory a carry >> is foreign
pack Oh, in this case
>> which is a foreign in this case foreign
pack incentivized for the special interest of one group and only
one. >> But the but hold on. It's not incentivized for
the interest of a group, right? It's in it's it's incentivizing
it's advocating for the national interest of another country.
It's not one group. It's not like it's it's one group. So the
argument they'll give you is, well, these Americans, their number
one issue, just like they they don't want guns. They want Israel
taken care of. That's their number one issue. It's like, okay,
but that's different. They're not trying to make America better.
They're trying to make Israel better.
That's that's fundamentally a misalignment of
of goals, of incentives. Okay? Yes, these people can do this,
but they their goal is to make Israel, is to enrich Israel, is
to make Israel safe and better. No matter what Israel does,
that is not
that is not the same, right? That is not the same at all.
>> One group with no financial transparency. I think that
that's really bad. Okay. True fact. There are 8 billion in the
world >> and you're
again just totally trivializing. Just no concern whatsoever.
Um it's I mean it's fine, but it's not fine. It's not fine. And
these people suck. These people suck. I really hope she's getting
paid for it. If she's not getting paid for it, it's very embarrassing.
She's the only person who is an Israeli shill without getting
a check and a border.
I'm not going to go there. >> Gosh. Okay. Hey, Ardite,
what's your opinion on >> chill? We need to chill. Need
to be >> Do you think there are positives about
>> Sort of. It It feels like >> Is this lock Is this
looks maxing? I don't care. Um, there's one more clip. There's
one more clip. She was doing Collins
and a caller asks her, "Okay,
if you could bring one, do not answer, by the way. Do not answer
just in case you spoil. Do not answer. Do not say. But the caller
asks, if you could bring back one streamer, just one, who who's
stopped streaming, who would it be and why?" Okay,
get ready for this. >> The first one, if you could bring
back any one stream >> Oh, whoops. >> Here we go.
from any any time period, Twitch, poll, anywhere. Who would you
bring back and why?
>> Um, Reckful.
>> Okay,
now
now that's a crazy answer. Okay, that's a crazy answer because
I don't think
watched streams while RTF was popular,
I I don't think I don't think she watched streams while Reckful
was popular. I don't think she had any idea who Reckful was before
the Mr. Girl stuff happened. I don't think any of that is the
case.
Why would she pick Reckful? You don't know anything about Reckful?
Why did you pick Reckful?
That's crazy. Now, just just wait cuz you you say, "Oh, well,
you know, she's friends with people who were friends with him
and and she wants him to come back." Maybe that would be at least
a reasonable answer. Do you think that's what she said? you would
bring back Reckful.
>> I think he was just very creative. Um, he was very I
just think I I think the I I think that streaming space would
look a lot different if Reckful was still
>> He was just really creative.
What What did he do that was creative? What did he What did he
do that was creative? I'm not even saying he's not creative,
but like what is she aware of? And you can tell she's being vague.
She doesn't have specific things she liked.
He was very creative.
does she know? He killed himself. I do think she knows that.
Yeah, maybe that's what she means. Maybe that's what she means.
Most people they pick a building. They pick like an office building
or something. This guy did it off his own balcony. Maybe she
saw the chalk outline. There's like crime scene photos. There's
a chalk outline. Maybe he did something cool there. Maybe he's
working with a medium very few people get to.
Hard to say.
She watched Destiny videos. That's it. That to me, that's probably
what it is. I think she knows that other people would say that.
I It's It's just goofy,
>> Because he was so creative.
Like, there's so many reasons you could give,
hey, uh, he, you know, it seemed like he died. I I followed the
Mr. Girl stuff. He died before his time.
I I'd like him to have another chance and rethink things to see
how it affected people. You could give such a thoughtful answer
here. You could give like anything, but nothing. He was really
creative, actually.
Okay. All right. I don't even know if he was CUZ I DIDN'T WATCH
HIM
AND I TALKED TO HIM. I'VE BEEN IN A VC WITH Reckful before. I
had no idea. I didn't watch his stream. He was doing some other
I met him one time. Yeah, I know he was good at WoW. I know he
played mage.
Wait, no, he played rogue. Venuki was the mage. I met him in
Venooi at some point. Anyway. Anyway,
sorry. I just get it just gets annoying. It just gets annoying
is all. Okay. It's just all performance. It's all
I don't know what person is there. I don't know if there's a
person there
It's very rough.